so welcome to this this sixth session in uh
the worlds of speculative fiction series this
is uh put on by the brookfield public library
it's a monthly series and the first one we
talked just in general terms about science
fiction and fantasy and world building and
how philosophy could fit in with that and
we've been looking at authors starting with
with j.r tolkien last month we did isaac asimov
and today we're going to do frank herbert
and i was actually going to try to talk about
the you know dune trilogy the first three
books but even just this is probably enough
for one night i'll make a few references to
it i think quite a few of you've read you
know a lot of the dunes stuff so we can have
some good conversation about that um so um
what we're what we're doing in this is we're
looking particularly at the notion of worlds
that's why i picked the authors that i did
ones who put a lot of time and effort into
constructing an entire narrative universe
and then looking at some of the philosophical
themes that are that are key in them i'm greg
sandler most of you know me already i'm a
local philosopher and speaker content producer
i do a few other things as well and i'm also
a long time speculative fiction fan for me
the reason why i pitched this series was because
this is my guilty pleasure i do a lot of reading
from my work but i don't get to do a lot of
this sort of reading for for my work so if
i can turn this into something work related
then i have an excuse to read as much of it
as i'd like and i i've been going back to
authors who i remember really enjoying when
i had more time when i was a teenager when
i was a college student it seems like from
graduate stud studies on i haven't had that
much time to actually do this so each of these
sessions is the same basic general structure
i do a few initial remarks and then we look
at some biographical and historical context
why this person is important what what formed
them um discussion of plot and character in
the narrative world and then i've usually
got sort of a an arsenal of philosophical
themes kind of handy but we could always talk
about other ones and for this one i mean there's
so many different themes going on just in
this one book that i picked up five that i
thought were particularly good but we can
certainly talk about others there's time for
general discussion and q a after everything
but i also encourage anybody to chime in whenever
they want comments questions all of that's
you know fair game i'm you know i've been
doing public speaking now in one way or another
for close to 20 years so i'm good at taking
you know tangents and bringing bringing things
back eventually to the main point so you don't
you don't have to have any worries about that
and we can go off into whatever you want to
discuss so a few remarks about frank herbert
and his work and his influence this is really
an extraordinary work in many respects because
it's it's one of the first sci-fi novels to
take an ecological explicitly ecological viewpoint
on things you see that woven into the story
itself and you can say well other people you
know were for nature like say tolkien you
know was clearly for nature and against mechanization
but he wasn't looking at things in terms of
system theory the way that herbert would um
it's also part of a newer wave of what they
call soft and in this case i'd like to say
softer rather than just soft science fiction
you know there's this tradition of what they
call hard science fiction where it was very
much about explaining some some ideas that
were scientifically oriented technology played
a major role in this there's lots of technology
but herbert never actually tells you how any
of it works uh he invents a few ideas about
you know this field or this transformation
but he doesn't tell you anything about that
because it's not that's not what's driving
the story it's not about how you know humankind
uses technology to solve the problems of of
the universe it's more about human beings
and what they're going through uh and what
they're doing so it also hit the right sort
of historical stride we're fortunate that
we've got some copies of the original serializations
in analog and then this was very quickly turned
into a novel this is we were just looking
at this this is not the the original way it
looks this is the i think you said 34th printing
uh of this yeah no 31st printing june 1984
so god knows how many printings it's gone
through at this point but this is a a what
you could call a campus novel so like tolkien's
lord of the rings and like strange hindland
stranger in a strange land and a few other
works uh it hit just the right time for a
primarily american but to lesser extent i
think british college campuses and there were
certain themes associated with it that fit
in with that so by the time that the counterculture
starts forming this is one of their books
in certain respects um so that that's you
know an important thing about influence arthur
clark who is a major science fiction author
said that this this work was unique in the
depth of its characterization and the extraordinary
extraordinary detail it creates and he said
i know of nothing comparable to it except
for the lord of the rings so that kind of
gives you an idea of the vastness of scope
and there have been some interesting uh writing
some studies about how tolkien engages in
world creation and how herbert does it they're
similar in that both of them make up an entire
you know vocabulary and you know create almost
like sort of like all these back stories we're
talking about the other dune books that have
come out that's been possible precisely because
there's so much back story that's being referred
to now myself i i read dune as a middle schooler
we've got some people in here who read it
when it first came out uh it was very cool
i i you know i don't go back that far myself
i was born in 1970 but i i encountered dune
when i was in my you know early teens i think
or maybe what they now call preteens and i
was fascinated by it i thought it was great
stuff um and then you know there's a little
bit more biographical information for me i
saw the movie when it came out and i thought
it didn't make an awful lot of sense compared
to the book and the david lynch version but
i thought it was super cool that there was
a movie about it to begin with um i was also
into heavy metal and i still am actually and
one of my favorite bands iron maiden on one
of my favorite records has a song which they
wanted to title doom they actually wrote herbert
and tried to get permission from him and he
said i don't like that kind of music he didn't
like rock and roll to begin with and he really
didn't like heavy metal and so they called
it to tame a land but if you listen to the
song it like it brings up all sorts of things
about paul being the quizzes cataract and
the div and the fremen and all this this stuff
so you know it was part of my sort of popular
consciousness and i was very attracted to
this character paul as well because you know
he's a hero and he's got all this great training
he's doing all this this wonderful stuff so
i you know to go back to it as an adult was
quite interesting you know you read things
very differently i think as a teenager than
you do in your you know in your more mature
years um and i found too going back to the
other books i didn't really like the follow-ups
much when they came out now i really like
him because i can understand what he was trying
to do that i had no idea when i was a kid
what was going on so um herbert himself i've
given you a literary timeline and it doesn't
have all of his works in there just just you
know quite a few of them and it doesn't have
every single aspect of his life because i
wanted to fit this all on one page but it's
good for giving you a sense of you know when
he was and what he was doing he's born in
1920 and he's born in the the northwest he's
born into a family that does a lot of hunting
and fishing uh you know outdoors sort of life
they also do a lot of drinking and that's
part of why he leaves to go and live with
his anthem's uncle but he spent a lot of time
with his father who was at one time a trooper
and uh you know they would drive around and
shoot at things and you know do all sorts
of fun things by the age uh by age eight he'd
already decided he wanted to be an author
the story is that on his eighth birthday and
back then apparently you got to have off on
your birthday you'd have to go to school um
he had a special meal and he got up and he
said i'm going to be an author and he started
trying to write stuff according to him it
wasn't very good which is not surprising you
know any of you who've done writing if you
go back and you look at your early efforts
as i've done you're not very proud of them
usually but you know it's very important for
growing um so you can see that you know he
he ends up getting through high school and
then immediately starts a journalism career
and he does a lot of journalistic writing
in part to pay the bills but in part because
that's that's you know what you do as a writer
if you're going to make your living is that
you do that sort of thing he gets married
pretty young he's only 20 years old when he
gets married that marriage does not work very
well he they have a daughter he registers
for the draft by the time that he does that
the marriage is already on the rocks he ends
up becoming a photographer in the navy taking
pictures for the seabees which are kind of
an elite unit in certain respects i kind of
like them because i was in the army as a combat
engineer and that's what the seabees essentially
were for the navy um he uh by that time his
wife is already you know starting to tell
him it's over i want a divorce 1943 he gets
injured um he trips actually out on biv whack
and and has an injury to his head he gets
honorably discharged it takes until 45 before
the divorce is actually finalized and at that
time he starts selling pulp stories and he
doesn't start writing science fiction right
away he's writing other kinds of stuff and
that's probably pretty important too for his
you might say apprenticeship as a writer we
saw something similar a few months back and
we talked about eve and voight and his development
he was writing a lot of pulp stuff now he
meets his his next wife he gets the gi bill
so he uh goes to college he actually doesn't
do well in college because he only takes the
classes he wants to take he has no interest
in getting a degree or you know fulfilling
requirements or anything like that he just
wants to learn what he wants to learn which
in a certain respect is kind of admirable
i can understand that that sort of business
in college and he meets this this woman beverly
ann stewart in a creative writing class and
she's a writer too she's writing more confessional
novels or natural novels even uh just you
know sort of pulp stuff and um they end up
uh uh you know marrying oh yeah i actually
didn't put when he got married in there soon
soon after that they they have a several children
they move to california she ends up being
the main breadwinner for quite a while working
in advertising so that he can focus on his
career as a writer he does some political
work as well i don't have that in here but
he does some speech writing uh apparently
none of the candidates that he ever wrote
speeches for won and the ones that there were
there was one that he began writing speeches
for and that guy then started losing after
that so but i don't think it had anything
to do with you know being a bad writer or
you know that sort of thing i think it's just
you know sort of bad luck he starts to write
sci-fi in in the 50s and his first story i've
got here is looking for something i haven't
read it myself but you notice that he starts
to to churn out things at this point and dune
which is in many respects the pinnacle of
his career has a long back story according
to the interviews that he's done it it goes
about 15 years back he starts getting interested
in sand dunes when he sees what's happening
in oregon and then he eventually decides he's
going to write a story about it the story
never gets published but he starts taking
notes and the notes that he he takes start
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and i know what that's like i i actually have
a book myself on something totally different
than i never intended to write a book about
um i started doing some research into this
this debate that happened in the 1930s about
between these french intellectuals about the
possibility of christian philosophy and i
thought it was just you know a small debate
between a few guys and the more and more research
that i did most of which i did at the university
of notre dame um i found that there were about
50 different people involved and it spanned
this you know whole you know six year period
uh and and you know there are books of journal
articles and all that and i i actually have
uh still at this point in time although we're
going to eventually get rid of these these
documents when we digitize them uh two file
cabinet drawers just filled with photocopies
of documents from from that debate now herbert
wasn't looking at just a small thing like
a bunch of french intellectuals in the 1930s
he was looking at ecology and how sand dunes
would you know play into things and he's he's
watching uh things like the the progression
of the sahara desert and so he's taking notes
on all this stuff and you know predict you
know predictably enough that's not gonna really
work for a you know journal story it's it's
it's uh it's become something much larger
so he starts uh working on it and eventually
it's serialized we we're fortunate that we've
got some original uh copies of the the analog
stuff floating around here so that that's
really cool it's a lot of science fiction
at that time was indeed serialized it was
brought out come on in it was brought out
you know bit by bit by bit this was very common
not just for science fiction but i mean it
goes all the way back you know dickens a lot
of the stuff that he wrote was serialized
dostoyevsky and you can tell sometimes when
something's serialized because of the way
that the chapters end you know often have
a cliffhanger uh and so when you when you
de-serialize it sometimes you take out some
of that stuff or you smooth over the transitions
or you fix plot holes and it looks like herbert
did a bit of that so dune comes out and when
it comes out on the one hand nobody wants
to publish it he goes to about 20 different
publishers pitching it he even does an ad
campaign to try to get them to you know use
some of the techniques from the advertising
trying to get publishers interested even uh
campbell john campbell who had serialized
it passed on he said i don't want to publish
this so finally he gets chilton who at that
time was was only publishing books on automotive
parts uh as far as i know they publish it
they take a chance and it gets snatched up
and people are you know they really want to
do it and then people then some publishers
are you know they see the light and they're
like yeah we really should publish this this
stuff and now you know we have it in easy
paperback form wherever you go he wins a nebula
award for it he wins a hugo award he actually
ties with roger zelazny for that um and then
he you know he goes on and he starts working
on other projects uh he will write a number
of other dune uh story novels but by the third
one he actually wants to be done with it we
were talking about this before we started
and the publishers and the fans just keep
after him over and over again so finally he
relents and the stuff comes out he um you
know he spends a lot of time as a professional
writer he also does quite a few other interesting
things with his wife and
towards the end of his life things start to
to in certain respects get get very interesting
but also rather tragic his wife dies shortly
before he himself dies the movie dune is is
released kind of bittersweet in part because
david lynch his version of it it's very difficult
to take something like this and turn it into
a feature like the movie i think an hour and
a half is what you've got to work with about
three movies yeah think about what they did
in lord of the rings even that they had to
leave out so much stuff i do actually have
something i'm going to pass around i don't
remember this but apparently the studio started
handing out handouts because people were getting
confused about what the hell is this you know
they're referring to all these things in the
movie so they sort of brief people beforehand
okay these are the terms that you're going
to encounter i'll pass that around and you
know those of you who have read it you'll
you'll know what all these things mean but
imagine an audience are just getting there
and they've never read this um there's people
around them of course who have they're in
on the secret uh and now they're like what
is what is going on here you know there's
no points of reference um and the movie didn't
do very well which was kind of a shame there
was actually an attempt to create the movie
beforehand um a long-standing uh you know
thing that just sort of fell through which
is unfortunate as well herbert dies in in
86 his health really started to fail in 85
he gets diagnosed with a pancreatic with pancreatic
cancer your you know prognosis for that even
today is still pretty bad um back then it
must have been you know he really must have
been living on borrowed time so you know his
career comes to a close in in the 80s he never
really with any of these books that he publishes
after he never enjoys quite the critical acclaim
that dune brought him but they are pretty
good you know i i like them i imagine quite
a few of you like them as well and he manages
to essentially create an entire universe or
the kernel of the universe in this book so
before we go on to talk about the world any
any questions or comments that you guys or
discussion that you guys want to engage in
they did they did another movie later oh the
sci-fi mini series right yeah yeah yeah that
was they i think they gave like about now
was it like four episodes but they're not
quite two hours because there's so much commercial
time four episodes yeah there's came out on
dvd it's that on dvd yeah i mean to really
do something like this justice you need so
much time you know it's tough to do but yeah
i saw this i was very excited when the sci-fi
one came out it was in the 2000s wasn't it
yeah yeah early 2000s yeah
well let's let's talk about his world then
or does people call it the dunivers and he
really is we talked about asimov last last
time working on the scale of the whole galaxy
right and that's what herbert's doing we have
these vast amounts of time all the events
in this take place 10 000 years after the
butler in jihad and we don't know when that
happened in relation to our own earth history
it's sometime in the distant future humankind
has has scattered itself among the stars there
is an empire in place but there's also people
living beyond the realm of the empire it's
it's you know just as vast as azamat's foundation
series and so you've got this interstellar
empire that's in place that's providing a
lot of stability
and there's there's even a universal language
that you know there's different dialects of
and people sometimes have trouble understanding
each other called galac uh after the galaxy
i suppose there's technology but one of the
key things that has happened is that butlerian
jihad that butler and jihad is a reaction
against machines and against artificial intelligence
in particular so humans take place of machines
for many processes really anything that requires
active intelligence it's done by human beings
and you know there's this this uh we'll talk
about the orange catholic bible in a moment
but one of the verses from it is thou shalt
not make a machine in the likeness of a human
mind that's one of the prohibitions uh that
comes out of that so there's a lot of development
of specialized trainings that that cultivate
certain human potentials you know the spacing
guild plays an important role with that the
the the benny guesserath uh there's various
fighting systems that that develop out of
that these people call mentats that we'll
talk about and then doctors so there's people
that are taking human capacities and honing
them and developing them as far as possible
from generation to generation to generation
so that human beings could take the place
of thinking machines there's also a feudal
social system or sometimes a tribal social
system in place throughout most of the galaxy
you've got the emperor on top and then you've
got these ruling houses the you know the the
major houses they're called and minor houses
and they're all part of this thing called
the lonzrod and i've actually got a handout
to make sense of some of this for you um and
then uh there's the rest of the the poor bastards
that are the rest of humanity who serve everybody
else or it may be you know fairly free like
the fremen are on their planet but most people
are stuck under one of these noble houses
or a trading conglomerate or something like
that they've got somebody telling them what
to do and how to live and so it's really like
much of human history you know uh except for
people who are in hunter-gatherer societies
or in some other for fairly egalitarian society
most people get bossed around most people
have their their lives kind of dictated to
them there's struggles going on between these
houses and also with other organizations um
some of them are you know long-standing feuds
like between the two major houses that that
play a lot of the role of the plot the harkonnens
and the trainees going back you know thousands
of years they fight with assassins everybody
has to watch their back all the time there's
there's actually an interesting place in here
where jessica um you know realizes how free
she is in the desert she doesn't have to worry
about poison all the time or you know who's
going to stab her in the back and it's sort
of liberating and surprising to her because
that's not the norm there's some really interesting
ways in which religion plays into this that's
one of the themes that we'll talk about
and there's been a lot of evolution and syncretism
of religion by that time so there's religious
sex that essentially um herbert made up like
the the zen the zen sunnis who are the fremen
are an example of the orange catholic bible
is this document that's produced by this massive
ecumenical effort after the butler in jihad
the jihad was this struggle in which humanity
overthrows the machines and then you know
a few generations after that the religion
is still playing a major role and so they're
like well we should probably try to all get
on the same page and uh it doesn't go particularly
well um there's actually an appendix devoted
to it in the book it you know produces all
these riots and things don't go as quickly
but they they they come out with a document
the orange catholic bible that manages to
sort of smoosh together all the religions
uh at least the ones that are participating
and call out what they thought was the uh
the essential teachings uh but it takes a
lot of um you know backing by by important
uh factions to get this thing accepted um
the the bene gesture who we're gonna talk
about it a bit they managed to seed the universe
as much as possible with what they call the
missionaria protectiva the whole set of legends
and ideas focused around religion that they
can tap into when they're on a foreign world
and that that plays a major role in what happens
in the book um technology like i said the
technology in this is uh you're not allowed
to have you know thinking machines but you're
allowed to have all sorts of other cool stuff
like force shields and ships that can travel
between the stars and herd is really smart
with this he never he never tells you how
anything works it's just there to support
the plot to make things happen to open up
possibilities he doesn't get into any sort
of you know he does tell you that a few things
are based on this principle or that field
but he doesn't tell you anything about it
because he's not interested in that sort of
thing he's interested in what people make
of them so they have really cool things like
you know poison snoopers you know you can
have this this device that would be up in
the chandelier and sniff out the poison in
in that people are putting into your food
in your drink paul grabs this thing called
the hunter seeker which is you know this this
kind of floating thing that will go around
and you know find its victim and then burrow
up inside of you and i think if i remember
it that goes in your brain or something like
that so there's a lot of you know really cool
technology developed um some of the stuff
that we're familiar with atomic weapons you
know they they're they're not supposed to
be using those uh but every once in a while
they do
now there's there's also all this this stuff
going on and i created a handout for you to
try to help you those i think those of you
have read this and sort of digested it all
this is old hat to you anybody who hasn't
this can be a useful score card for what's
going on we have these houses and there's
three houses that play any significant role
in in this book house carino is the ruling
house the the empire um shadow iv is the emperor
and theoretically everybody's under him they
their their main source of power besides vast
wealth is these uh elite fighting forces the
sardakar and they are trained on this this
prison planet which is hellish conditions
um they are tougher than everybody else at
least until later on in the book when it turns
out that they're not the toughest guys house
harkonnen is another one of the major houses
they were originally banished for cowardice
and the tradies played a major role in that
this happened millennia ago and they've been
getting themselves back up in part through
economic building through through trade they're
also very brutal they're the ones who control
the desert planet maracas uh at the beginning
of the novel and they will control it through
a good portion of it they're out to kill the
atreides they're but they're out to destroy
them and baron vladimir harkonnen is the main
protagonist he's got two nephews who play
a major role one who he doesn't like the other
one who he really does like fade um and who's
he's kind of grooming and they they're really
well connected they're gonna end up you know
being the main bad guys in the story house
of tradies this is where the the heroes are
coming from lido uh is is the duke and he's
going to die very early on in the story they
live on kaladan they are known for their nobility
their their you know fair dealings they're
they're justice uh they're sort of the white
hat guys although there's you know there's
nobody who's totally good in herbert stories
um and then there's the lawns rod the lawns
rod are all these noble houses and they are
sort of a check on the power of the emperor
they get together lonsrod is you know this
old word that herbert liked it like tolkien
did like to take old words and use them for
new purposes and the lonzo was in sort of
an assembly of the nobles um sort of think
about like you know what was going on in the
english magna carta right we talked about
that as the barons the nobles asserting their
power against the king and being sort of a
counter force that's what's going on constitutionally
in in the dune thing and then there's this
uh choam or koam company which nice mix match
of different words here the combine onet ober
advancer mercantilis they're the ones that
control economic trading throughout the the
known universe so they're incredibly rich
all the noble houses have staked them some
of them get to be directors this is the source
of their power their their wealth and one
of the key commodities that's being traded
is this spice melange that the desert planter
dune is the only place where you can get and
that spice ends up being incredibly important
not only for for you know people who get addicted
to it but also for some of these other factions
that are playing a role here the spacing guild
these are humans that uh you know early on
all the way going back you know ten thousand
years to the time of butler in jihad they
were developing these the high level mathematics
and the associated sort of mental capacities
that would go along with it and they weren't
doing it just you know for the sake of like
we love math or something like that they did
it so that they could understand space and
time and the ultimate effect of that is being
able to travel between the stars guild navigators
are the you have to have them because otherwise
you can't carry out the calculations required
to get from point planet planet a to planet
b so without the gill there wouldn't be any
any reliable space travel which means they
have a monopoly on that which means they can
charge anybody whatever they like to get from
point a to point b and if the guild wants
to screw you over you're you're done you can't
get off planet and they they play you know
an important role um they also use spice in
order to be able to do this so they're dependent
on that planet uh the bene jesuit is another
order of you could think of them as in some
respects superhumans by training and these
are these are all women and they go all the
way back to the time of the butler in jihad
as well they were uh you know people who were
experimenting with the you know the role what
what drugs could do for you or what certain
training could do for you and bringing all
of them under they they talk about them as
witches or sorceresses but it's really all
based on what we might call technologies of
the self technologies by which we we activate
human potential and they have a uh important
role they do a lot of back room maneuvering
uh many of the noble houses will have you
know uh uh you know the males will have a
wife or a consort who's from the benedezura
and because of that they really run a lot
of the show and they're doing this in part
because they're they're engaging in this massive
breeding program they want to bring about
uh a person who is called the quizzes hatterack
and they've got all these great terms you
know that he brings up right and the quizzes
cataract is this messianic figure who's going
to be able to do the stuff that the ben and
jessica themselves can't do and they're already
like way beyond where most human beings are
so this guy is going to be able to be in all
places at once he's going to have divine attributes
essentially he's going to be able to see they
talk about being able to like look back into
all these places you know being able to understand
everything about their bodies uh capture the
old memories of people who've preceded them
but there's still a place where they can't
look that it terrifies them to look to and
the the quizzitz cataract is going to be able
to look there and we'll be able to understand
everything so it's kind of an interesting
idea they don't really know what he's going
to be but they're trying to breed him and
the way that they do this is by taking what
they view as the best humans from all these
noble houses and you know mix a little bit
here and a little bit there and marry them
off and this has been going on for thousands
of years that they've been doing this so they
they played an important role i i also mentioned
the missing area protectiva these are legends
and prophecies and practices that the bene
jesuit have established on all these worlds
through the galaxy so when one of them shows
up there they've already got something in
place where they can say oh you know i'm i'm
you know you've been looking you've been waiting
for the reverend mother here i am and here's
the signs by which you're going to know me
pretty smart and it's interesting so bad gesture
sounds uh very close to jesuit and there's
a reason for that frank herbert uh had these
ants who were very religious and he you know
back at that time now the jesuits might get
in trouble for you know some of the stuff
i'm going to say because i've got some colleagues
that are jesuits but the jesuits are not what
they used to be as a religious order they
used to be pretty pretty adroit you know when
it came to political maneuvering and all that
sort of stuff there was a word jesuitical
that people would use to to describe somebody
who could bend the truth just exactly the
right amount and there's good historical reasons
for why that was the case um herbert was around
when the jesuits were still like that and
the jesuits were very different when it came
to mission work this is part of why they they
ended up like getting kicked out of china
they it was felt that they went too native
when they would do their mission work um the
the chinese thing that's a long story but
it really has to do with how you translate
the word god into chinese and they they use
the word tian which means heaven and that
got them in trouble with with you know some
of the more orthodox orders back in the 1600s
or so what the jesuits would do is they would
have one guy come in and that guy as opposed
to the other orders who come in and that guy
would be going to bring the cross and start
preaching and organize a chapel i can't just
observe and see what was going on and see
if he could figure out the language of these
people and the customs of these savages that
he was living with and then he would take
notes and this would go on for years and then
the next generation would come in and this
guy would brief him and then he'd go back
to wherever you know the order was right and
the new guys there would have this stuff that
they could work with they wouldn't be just
sort of traipsing in and you know um like
the proverbial bull in the china shop only
in terms of like religion and ideology ticking
off the native people by telling them that
they're all going to hell if they don't get
baptized the jesuits are more the you know
we're going to do some market research you
know we're going to figure out how to how
to sell this stuff because we got the best
product in town you know god and so there's
some modeling of of the bene gesture it explicitly
on herbert's part he tells you this in interviews
after the jesuits and the missionary of protectiva
is like that it's going to play a major role
because paul and jessica are able to use it
to their advantage and then we've got the
last important group of people uh the freud
and the fremen are originally uh one of these
you know sort of minority uh groups of religious
people the zen sunnis that are wandering around
they spend some time in slavery here and there
and eventually they make it to a raucous where
they adapt to the very harsh desert climate
and become some of the most dangerous people
in the world or in the universe because conditions
are so difficult on a raucous that if you're
weak you die and so over time you know just
genetically they're developing you know for
example their blood coagulates like that which
is very important if you're in a you know
environment where water is is everything
they have all this you know stuff going on
on arrakis that nobody else knows about until
uh paul and jessica end up sort of getting
into that so we should talk that's all world
stuff right we should talk about the plot
then the plot and i'm going to go through
this very quickly is these noble houses are
feuding house of tradies is supposed to take
over a raucous and what's happening is there's
a trap lane for them house archonan is in
league with the emperor and they're going
to engineer a sort of you know combined military
attack that is going to destroy house of tradies
the reason they're doing this is because the
duke has been training soldiers that are almost
as good as the saudi car so it's threatening
the emperor's position harkonnen wants to
destroy him anyway um and you know vito the
the duke when they get to a raucous not only
does he have his own fighting men he sees
the fremen and their their toughness as a
possible resource that he might be able to
use them as well as a military force so they
want to they want to destroy them and so all
these these um people are sort of in league
against you know the emperor house are conan
um the spacing guild is complicit in this
all these people are coming down you know
like you've ever been in a meeting where you
walk in and you think you're only facing off
against one person and it turns out that you
know there's been stuff happening and everybody's
against you right yeah have you ever been
in that sort of situation yeah so that's now
imagine that except with knives you know okay
and lots and lots of killing long story short
um duke leo is killed
and most of his men are killed a few of them
escape and become renegades working with these
um
smugglers and paul who's his son and his wife
who's a benign jessica they escape into the
desert with these these fretmen and eventually
they because of the missing area protectiva
paul has already been seen as as this religious
figure the nadi this is something that that
comes directly from uh you know what we could
call terrestrial islam right there mahdi means
something like the the savior the awaited
one different people have been called the
mahdi at different points in time here in
our you know narrative framework uh of our
history uh i think the last one was uh sometime
in the 20s in somewhere in sudan the british
killed him and uh i'm very hazy about that
so i'm sure somebody will correct me at one
time or another but the mandi is supposed
to be the savior figure and he's going to
um sort of have automatic knowledge of everything
so one of the things that the freman wears
is still suits it covers you from head to
toe keeps your water from uh you know from
getting lost it recycles all your water then
you can you can sip it you know through it
throughout the day uh uses your waste to do
that uses your sweat and it takes a lot of
i guess buckling you know the right way to
put it on there's a lot of attachments to
it and paul figures out how to do it right
away because in part because paul is as it's
going to turn out he is the quizzes cataract
he is this person who's been bred for generations
after generation uh he just came one generation
too early because he was supposed to be a
girl but his mother chose to make him a boy
instead they have this sort of capacity to
do that and so he's got everything going for
him so on the one hand you've got everybody
against you and on the other hand the hero
and his mother have all the advantages they
have the bene jesuit training both for her
and for him they have these incredibly resourceful
you know super fighter uh highly adaptive
fremen who think that they're essentially
like one step away from god and really in
many respects they are and to make it even
better the spice has uh properties it doesn't
just get you high you know the way like people
do drugs around here you know like they shoot
up heroin they're not actually like seeing
the face of god or seeing all the time they
may think they are but um probably not right
this stuff actually does open up the consciousness
and paul is able to make use of all of this
sort of stuff long story short he's able to
surprise all the people who have essentially
screwed them over he's able to threaten the
guild and say i'm going to destroy all the
spice unless you guys give in to us he gets
the emperor and the harkonnens to come to
arrakis to finally wipe him out and when he
when they they do under the cover of a sandstorm
and riding sand worms and using atomics to
destroy the shield wall that keeps the sand
from coming in they have a massive military
victory and they're able to you know destroy
the harkonnen power they're able to make the
emperor give in he gets to marry the emperor's
daughter and now all the atreides are on top
and that's the end of the story there's one
other important wrinkle paul this whole time
once he becomes conscious of who he is and
what's going on he can see the future but
he can see multiple futures and in one of
those futures there is another jihad happening
but it's not you know when we hear the word
jihad you know we think of like people fighting
in one place in the world right this is across
the entire universe and he wants to prevent
that you know we talk about you know thousands
of people dying here we're talking about trillions
of people dying and he wants to keep that
from happening but he's the one who's also
sort of unleashing the jihad so how do you
ride a wave like that how do you how do you
you know keep it from you know turning into
a tsunami is the question and he can see you
know different paths go leading off into the
future so you know for example he he chain
you know he sees that if i choose my name
this way jihad right maybe if i choose this
name slightly different nachi god or a smaller
jihad or less life loss in the end he's not
actually able to keep it from happening and
this is one of the criticisms that was made
of the book by by campbell he said the hero
loses right i mean the hero does win everything
he's the ruler of the universe his house has
won the bad guys have been punished but he
also is unable to prevent the jihad that's
going to be coming that's going to cause incredible
human misery so i mean that's quite a universe
already just created in this book and then
there's more books after that you know in
which other things happen as well so before
we go on to any we're going to go through
the philosophical themes rather quickly um
any comments or questions about this sort
of vast scope of uh and i i left out like
90 of what happened that's a good summer oh
thanks yes thanks just a pointed question
yes because i've been a long time since i've
read the book so i was a teenager yeah my
recollection was that uh that paul wasn't
really against the jihad well universe he
just he had difficulty reconciling himself
with it but he thought it was a necessary
thing it was part of the regeneration replenishing
of the vitality of the human race so there's
there's an aspect to that um he does think
that if and herbert thought this too there'd
be a sort of stability it turns into sterility
right but he does talk at a number of points
about wanting to keep to keep it from turning
into the jihad that he sees uh likely to happen
so it's in some respects it's like well do
we want to this is a little bit facetious
but do we want to just straight out jihad
or jihad with a human face you know because
you're not going to be able to keep you're
not going to be able to like keep anything
from happening but it's a question of how
devastating it's going to be and then later
on in the other books um there's you know
his son uh becomes this this god-like emperor
for thousands of years sees uh human beings
essentially there's a lot of different paths
where the human race itself will end up dying
and he establishes this golden path to try
to avoid that and part of it has to do with
that notion of well you got to stir things
up or else it gets stagnant and then the race
will will die out so yeah
yeah how how did he god there's so much stuff
here um how did you think of asimov and his
universe kind of developed over time yeah
as you wrote stuff this is the one the first
book yeah how did he keep all this straight
and how did he develop it is there any did
he did he talk about that at all did he have
great big flow charts all over the he had
tons and tons and tons of notes i don't know
i don't know about that like how he charted
it yeah um that's an interesting question
and i and i impressed all these people all
these different yeah you know this is something
we talked a little bit about last time if
you were going to try to write something of
that scope you probably would need something
like a spreadsheet right just to keep track
of everyone later on at the very end we're
going to talk about george rr martin who has
so many characters fortunately half of them
dying at any given time right but there's
just so many people in play and so many plot
lines how do you keep from even just like
making mistakes and mixing up one person for
another and then add in all these made up
or not actually made up a lot of them are
actually taken from arabic or persian all
these words you know that he uses um yeah
i mean he the one thing i can say is he the
research that he was doing on this took him
years and years and years i think the one
thing that might have helped him stay grounded
and use that plot device with having these
historical documents coming oh yeah so i mean
that kind of like he could write that stuff
and then he had to make everything fit yeah
there's little snippets too uh with before
each chapter where like ireland is telling
you a bit that that's an interesting device
because we've seen that in a lot of them yeah
dan voight did that asthma did that i'm starting
to actually see some things that i totally
missed when i was a kid reading these these
uh as an adult in terms of how you do narrative
worlds you know well should we talk about
some of the philosophical themes then so one
one really big one of course is religion what
is religion's meaning and role and you know
some people have said that that herbert was
just sort of you know anti-religious and he
was you know trying to show that religion
is basically just about power or domination
or you know superstition and i don't think
that really that really works because you
can't even if you think that it's you know
it's not something you would believe in you
can't invest that much time and thought and
sort of research into it without at least
becoming an admirer of certain religious viewpoints
and religion plays such a massive role in
dune and not just one religion but a whole
bunch of different religious aspects some
of the some of the characters in the dune
universe do see religion as something just
for those ignorant masses to be exploited
like the guild explicitly thinks that about
religion the benin gesture would kind of do
that because they've got that missing area
protectiva that's how you keep the you know
the savages from killing you when you land
on their planet you've already got some stuff
laid out by you know generations before you
uh another way of looking at religion and
this is i think what you see paul and tradies
himself um articulating in here and i think
this is probably closer to herbert's view
is that it's a way of making myth in in not
just the past from the present that it intersects
with um things that are that are real like
politics and economics and social structures
and then it reinterprets it and gives it a
transcendent meaning and that can be good
or it can be really bad you know like you
know jihad where everybody thinks of their
their cleansing the universe of the the infidels
you know that that can be pretty horrific
um and another another thing that they're
dealing with too is how to make sense out
of suffering um religion plays an important
role in that um now there's a couple interesting
quotes that i have directly from the book
that i think express different views on on
religion so one is when religion and politics
travel on the same card the writers believe
nothing can stand in their way their their
movements become headlong faster and faster
and faster they put aside all thoughts of
obstacles and forget the precipice does not
show itself to the man in a blind rush until
it's too late this is something that somebody's
saying to paul and that's part of what's what's
happening with the front you've got all these
religious forces aligning that's that's what's
going to give them the drive to take on pretty
much the rest of the known universe um and
so you know forces are being set in motion
another thing that and i forget exactly who
said this in the book i should have written
it down was much that was called religion
has carried an unconscious attitude of hostility
towards life truly true religion must teach
that life is filled with joys pleasing to
the eye of god that knowledge without action
is empty all men must see that the teaching
of religion by rules and wrote is largely
a hoax the proper teaching is recognized with
ease you can know it without fail because
it awakens within you that sensation which
tells you this is something you've always
known and so there's a distinction there sometimes
people talk about you know religion and spirituality
is different things i i think that's actually
not not that great of a distinction but that's
something sort of like what he's talking about
there that there's a lot of religion that
ends up being sort of going through the motions
and you know becomes part of the social structure
but why is religion around because when it's
working well it's there's something in people
that responds to it that says oh yeah i get
this this this gives transcendent meaning
and then he's got another passage religion
must remain an outlet for people who say to
themselves i am not the kind of person i want
to be it must never sink into an assemblage
of the self-satisfied so again contrast there
but in that case the emphasis is not just
on responding to something it's about well
how do i how do i make sense of the fact that
i'm screwed up and i'm not what i would like
to be or even what i pretend to other people
to be and then how would i if i do recognize
that and i feel bad about it how would i get
from this point to this point and that's something
that every major religious tradition has in
fact given us some teachings about it and
in fact a lot of those teachings tend to align
you know if you're out there killing your
neighbor or screwing them over it's going
to be really hard to move from that point
a realizing that you're not what you want
to be to point b um being something closer
to what you were intended to be and and so
that's you know there's a lot of interesting
facets to how religion plays into this and
there's it's you could say this that the role
of religion is ambiguous it's clearly very
important i don't think that herbert provides
you with a theory of what religion itself
is he provides you with sort of snippets and
that's probably as good as we can get on that
when you look at really good work in comparative
religion you know like huston smith for example
he won't try to say well here's the one thing
that all religions consist consistent instead
it's more like well there's this messy thing
we call religion and we never find religion
per se we always find judaism or islam or
you know buddhism and it's buddhism of this
this variety taught at this place and practiced
in this way um it's similar with with herbert
he doesn't you know he's got general remarks
about religion but then there's religions
and they play they play different roles and
different people within them some are hypocrites
some are uh very um oriented towards trying
to figure out what is this all about you know
so that's one one key theme another big theme
i think that is you know speculated a lot
about today and i hope this promotes some
interesting discussion is this whole thing
about the thinking machines and that we you
know dune is set in a period when mankind
has made a choice against the thinking machines
and the reason they made the choice was because
the thinking machines uh ended up screwing
them over and at first there's this great
line once men turned their thinking over to
machines in the hope that this would set them
free but that only permitted other men with
machines to enslave them this is the theme
that we've seen running throughout philosophy
aristotle talks about in his politics he talks
about why we need slaves and aristotle gives
a an argument for what he calls natural slavery
as it turns out most people who are slaves
according to aristotle's view shouldn't be
slaves most people who are masters shouldn't
be masters but there is still some scope for
that and then one of the things that he says
is if we had looms that would weave back and
forth to shuttle by themselves we would not
need slaves to do that so the promise is if
we had technology that was self-directing
and we didn't have to rely on the the tool
of tool the hand and the mind to do it but
we had you know self-directing technology
then we could all be more or less equal we'd
still have some problems you know people would
you know cheat on each other and you know
some people would kill each other but we would
certainly reduce the amount of that we could
reduce human misery jean-jacques rousseau
has a book called the origin of the uh the
discourse on the origin of inequality and
he sees technology is playing a major role
in that metallurgy in particular but also
agriculture technology by its its own nature
helps to produce uh more and more complex
societies those tend to be less and less egalitarian
and more and more given to all these social
forces um you know we have other so we've
got you know sort of two different views is
technology potentially liberating or is it
something that makes things worse while making
them better because it turns out it's usually
both right and a lot of technology is two-sided
and then when we get to artificial intelligence
you know we start thinking about robots or
whatever we're going to have and we start
thinking about things that are like us you
know we're not all that comfortable with it
some people are very uncomfortable with it
right there's been a lot of talk recently
about well should we have artificial intelligence
or are we setting ourselves up for some sort
of cataclysm there's quite a few big opinion
formers who have come out recently and said
we shouldn't pursue artificial intelligence
and herbert is playing with these themes you
know decades this is back in the 60s right
so 50 years ago he's bringing these these
issues of course he's not the only one but
he um frames it as human humankind makes a
decision we're not going to have thinking
machines so then the question is well how
are we going to get things done right because
if we're not going to have you know shuttles
that that move themselves um who's going to
do that work we're going to have to have some
sort of stratified society and that's what
we see in in this dune universe it's not it's
not one that that you would probably pick
if you didn't know where you're going to end
up you wouldn't say i want to be in frank
herbert's dune universe because most likely
you're going to be a peasant yeah right or
a tradesman or something like that you're
not going to be a great lord very you know
maybe a very tiny chance that you could yeah
and if you're a high monkey but then they're
trying to kill you all the time yeah well
all the other times are trying to kill you
yeah and the people under you are envious
of you that might try to kill you or might
betray you yes it's a it's not a great existence
for really everybody uh yeah there's not a
lot of characters in here are happy the fremen
are actually the happiest people because they
live in a fairly egalitarian society they're
free but they also you know they're in a tribal
society so they settle food they settle issues
even like leadership disputes by killing each
other so their life cycle you know lifespan's
not super long uh and that's if the desert
doesn't get you or the worms don't get you
or so but this is this idea about you know
um the thinking machines you know what are
our worries today you know we've got you know
science fiction things like skynet in the
terminator thing uh we have the matrix right
these machines in the matrix series is that
really what we're worried about happening
i think it's about just your relevance what
happens what happens to you well the robots
take your jobs um not just take your job but
i mean if ai is the next evolutionary step
then we are no longer human yeah so maybe
consciousness will just be and will no longer
need this so is it something that we want
to take that next step in our evolutionary
process or do we want to say well we have
to halt it at a point because we have to maintain
some relevance it cannot just be not useful
we can have no use yeah people can't live
without meaning as it turns out yeah they
can just sit and watch reality shows
how would you even do that no but you wouldn't
even have commerce you would have nothing
to maintain yeah you would be useless on the
other side is it frees up creativity that
the artificial intelligence takes care of
the routine and enables the relevance to be
in the area of creativity notice though that
a lot of creativity requires that you invest
a lot of time doing stuff that you don't want
to do so that you can acquire those skills
i'll use an example so i used to work with
an art department and so i talked with the
art professors and they were incredibly disciplined
right because they they had you know gone
through college and they were successful artists
and i i asked them what's what's you know
what's your number one complaint about your
students they said what we would really like
is to have you know these high school art
teachers quit telling their students that
they're talented because they come in and
they don't want to take the drawing class
they say i already know how to draw and you
know they offered like drawing one two three
you know all the way up because you need to
learn how to draw before you're gonna learn
how to paint and these students would be like
i already know how to do all this sort of
stuff i'm talented i'm a you know what do
we call it a precious snowflake or something
like that right and they'd be like no you
what you did in high school that's a great
little start but now we're gonna do it rigorously
so that someday you can actually have an inkling
of what you know da vinci was doing or michelangelo
was doing right because those guys were further
along and so there is a sense in which routine
stuff there's all this crap that we have to
do and we could be more creative but with
the things where the creativity reaches a
higher level how if you do like make everything
easy and then you know sort of sap the will
of human beings how are you going to get them
to be creative like that you know yeah well
i think there's two interesting things to
your point and then what you were also just
talking about and one is you know i was astounded
by the number of people who voted against
the minimum livable wage in switzerland 77
because there's this whole idea and you know
it's in dante and everything that if the state
takes care of its people the people will get
to the business of doing creative work yeah
the needs are met in a productive way and
not a you know sort of disadvantaged way that
people will be able to get to their creative
work and you would think that the number then
for voting for something like that would have
been more split or more equal not that 77
of the populists would have voted against
having a basic minimum wage that would have
sort of supported them to do whatever it was
that they needed to do um but the other thing
is i don't know if it's robots so much anymore
but it if social media is an indicator sort
of like where people are getting their news
then the big thing right now right is that
elon musk is telling people that we are indeed
part of the hologram and that there really
isn't you know a reality and so i think that
people are having very different conversations
about relevance and how we sort of pin our
relevance to something because if we are part
of this like mysterious you know non-thing
or part of a program or whatever it is then
are we even qualified to judge what relevance
would be in in the grander scale one of the
things that's come out of the elon musk thing
because he's one of the people saying ai is
going to kill us all right so somebody then
pointed out to him wait a second if you buy
into this like we're part of a hologram you
know we're then we're all the eyes right so
what are you complaining about matrix yeah
well go ahead yeah um uh you know i think
you set up something here with your analysis
throughout which is um and i think there's
like an existential thing yeah because you
know you can look at a lot of these different
um different um competing aspects of what's
going on here with the vinnie jessert in the
harkonnen and the house and just the houses
are about power you know you say what are
things about that's kind of the idea of just
who's in control and that's enough to be for
our purpose where has it been in jester i
said well no we need to figure we don't know
what the purpose is we have to find the purpose
and uh we can't look to this certain place
but they are but everybody's has a different
purpose in mind the space and guilds you know
just about getting places yeah you know it's
just we could just reflect you know if you
could get somewhere ever you don't have to
work you just get there kind of thing so there's
this kind of capacity that they're working
on and then then the harkonnen of course have
their you know resentment for being
well they very much enjoy hurting people they're
sadistic and so they that's where they get
their grants from the cruelty yeah part of
what their purposes are and you know for everybody
who's sort of on the bottom you can say well
you've got a purpose it's to make that stuff
that those people up there are telling you
what to do happen well no it's the religion
that gives the yeah that's that that they're
from whatever you know they they they've got
that idea they don't necessarily know what
it's about but it's there's something there
that we don't really get an idea what the
religion about is other than it's something
bigger we don't don't know why they care about
it
it's just you know it's just that this it's
their few it's almost like the chosen people
kind of frame yeah what was this structure
in place that uh sort of removed the pulse
of our clone i mean they're terribly corrupt
and everything yeah a lot of reasons maybe
that they collapsed but it didn't seem the
emperor was in charge to say a tree house
a treaty should take over they almost like
didn't want to or they don't you mean at the
beginning of the novel right yeah yeah i mean
i'm just trying to say what was the superstructure
there that orchestrated that the essential
component of the entire universe spikes yeah
was was going to be uh you know changed dramatically
in terms of who uh you know worked the extraction
and distribution it was a trap yeah the harconans
were they were in on it who appointed the
house of treaties
but the emperor was against them they're they're
setting up their trainings why did the amber
just say i'm going to take over all the things
oh okay so here's why because the lawns rod
which is that the so the lonz rod only plays
a role in the story by being what you could
possibly appeal to but never do so the emperor
needs to be able to destroy atreides but in
a way that won't get the rest of the houses
against him because they have enough power
together uh to oppose the emperor but if he
takes him out one at a time he wants the hard
counter to do it for him well he he gives
them so background politics yeah the essential
thing is spikes well he's just getting them
on to arrakis because that's a place where
their conan have been for a long time and
when they move out it's going to be easy for
them to move back in and attack it whereas
they they've tried i guess maybe i just yeah
and the power just get the spice oh because
harvested there's more than one essential
thing that's the thing with with herbert he
takes an ecological perspective on everything
there's never just one thing everything's
always like a whole bunch of systems interacting
with each other so you've got like these base
human motives like i'm going to get that sob
you know if i remember it correctly tradies
is so popular yeah it's so popular because
the lion's right is getting behind the tradies
yes
so it's all it's all this kind of everybody's
trying to keep the order in place exactly
in order to get rid of the treatment and if
you read the later books written by his son
it explains what happens between the narcolepsy
and the atreides oh yeah and there's references
to it in here but it gets very specific yeah
so the vintage starter like building is super
human but even that's not sort of yeah they
have to be there i mean there's people doing
things but what's enough and so that notion
of what of what um what a purpose is so that's
the classic cataract in some ways is the idea
of a purpose yeah and that but that purpose
just falls back on just keeping the human
race alive and fight vital yeah what's interesting
to me about that is why wouldn't you be just
as threatened by a superhuman as a computer
so that's that's that's one of the other things
that we're going to move to um that's a good
model the christ figure is the seeker and
it's embedded in the common interest in being
fair to people who fundamentally feel that
they've been screwed in 100 century no i think
there's a lot of psychological reason why
people feel more comfortable about it but
when you're just going down to the like is
it better at me than everything that i can
do yeah so what's my purpose now that it exists
is my purpose only to serve the computer is
my purpose only to serve this message figure
or is it in me and end of myself and which
is better or should i be should i be comfortable
with being for something else besides myself
so herbert says this about the dune trilogy
in a interview says the bottom line of the
dune trilogy is beware of heroes much better
to rely on your own judgment and your own
mistakes and that's so that you know you get
a hero who essentially becomes the guy who
takes over the universe in this and then that
continues on for a while and you can see something
else opposed to that early on in this book
that one of the reverend mothers who's examining
paul and tradies tells them this a world is
supported by four things the learning of the
wise the justice of the great the prayers
of the righteous and the valor of the brave
but all these things are as nothing without
a ruler who knows the art of ruling make that
the science of your tradition and the idea
is there we we call this pluralism we need
not just one principle one thing running the
whole show you know we need a number of different
competing values to keep things vital to keep
things you know in certain ways relevant right
to keep things going that opens up space for
people to then make their own mistakes now
of course if you make your own mistakes generally
in this this university die right or you're
or you're going to horrific slavery of some
sort but there there's a sort of uh you could
say a kind of rivalry of perspectives being
offered by frank herbert in there putting
these things in his character's mouths and
paul thinks about this later on when he's
trying to this very quote when he's trying
to figure out where does you know for example
stillgaard fit in is he one of these guys
is he one of these guys who's who's doing
this support work and he's thinking about
how to keep his own messianic stature from
contaminating all of his own relationships
so he talks about this still guard guy who's
the leader of the uh the freeman he's a planetary
yes or not well that's kings yeah well that's
kings kings okay yeah but stillgar starts
out as a friend and then how do you keep a
friend from turning into a disciple because
if they turn into a disciple then you're right
why is that any better than being a disciple
of a computer you know so there is this this
you know issue about you know sort of super
humans and world history and how is that good
for the rest of us but there is also this
tendency to say well if we just had a superhuman
then we'd fix everything right we wouldn't
have all this messy politics and people trying
to somebody's impose order it'd be so great
you know and we see this with what's going
on with our you know supporters of our presidential
candidates there are some some very uh reasoned
supporters of the three main candidates who
are left and then you know some of the uh
lesser party candidates that are also out
there like the greens and the libertarians
but then there's also a lot of people who
are like this person is going to fix everything
we just have to have this person in and if
you don't want me to have this person in i'm
going to eat the crap out of it like this
year we don't want that person yeah there's
well there's always some of that there's always
all that yeah there's always people i mean
citizens just abdicate the responsibility
of citizens yeah to to put everything on the
back of one person like they're going to fix
it but we all as citizens have the responsibility
to you know not not to have just have one
machine or one messiah or one person because
and even some of these leaders have said that
and even you know paula trevis as more deep
said you know to still whatever that guy that's
the story so yeah what if everybody had the
water's elected he was enlightened that know
that it's you know we are not to fight each
other work together it's no longer going to
be taken off leadership you know we have to
come together and and and work this out so
he actually got the you know the revelation
of what that pure consciousness kind of thing
was and coming together you know there's actually
a piece from another interview that i um that
has to do with that incident that i put in
here because i wanted to talk about it in
a different respect um and herbert talked
about the difference between the the moral
and the ethical and and people use these in
different ways and the way that he was talking
about it was the moral being sort of moral
norms that are imposed on people by their
environment by their culture and so he says
it's fixed how as how many wives a man and
his culture may be able to have to be able
to support or what possessions he can carry
from one stopping place to another and how
this would control the moral law that we build
up in society he says we see it in our society
for example our nomadic background herdsmen
background we see all kinds of moral injunctions
which grew out of that and which we accept
today logically and he says i'm not trying
to denigrate them but where this moral where
this moral law comes from ethical law takes
a step in another direction and it says that
i the thinking animal see that the logical
consequences of the moral actions are such
and so and i'd better modify the moral law
slightly by a higher ethical law and exactly
that circumstance where paul for those who
don't remember or haven't read that part paul
is facing off with stilgar because paul is
increasing in power and the way you're supposed
to take power is kill the person who's the
other challenger to your your leadership he's
friends with stilgar and he thinks i also
need this guy you know i don't want to just
kill him and so paul he's got this long speech
that you probably remember more where it's
just well why should we kill off all of our
important people because if this doesn't make
any sense to take all of our leadership out
so that's an example that herbert saw you've
already got moral norms in place and usually
they're pretty good they're better than like
we just fight each other and do whatever we
want you know they keep some sort of order
but then we have to think more like humans
we have to we have to go to a higher level
and modify that and then make an argument
like that you know and he does he makes an
argument he doesn't just say here's what we're
doing it's my choice he says let's think about
this let's talk about he invites them almost
on an equal basis yeah relationships and leadership
so then that again um uh part of the kim you
know the campbell heroes journey thing when
they you know he goes through all of that
and then when you come out on the other side
you're supposed to be serving humanity so
yeah i could see where camel gently got a
little freaked out because he didn't i mean
he only kind of did he got the boon but he
didn't go back um so yeah i mean i that's
kind of what i what i took out of that is
that he he broke that structure of what was
going on and put a new structure in place
at a higher level of consciousness that he
achieved one of the one of the key themes
that runs throughout this and it shows up
very early on with the the test with the gom
javar is who is really human and who is in
human flesh but really just an animal and
this is you know a common philosophical issue
that has been talked about by all sorts of
people the gamma bar is this this box you
put it in your hand in and the gamma bar is
actually if i remember it's the needle that
the the lady's got a poison on she's going
to stab you with if you pull your hand out
of the box and the box this is a good example
of herbert making up some technology nerve
induction i think he called it or something
anyway it makes it it starts well with a little
bit of pain and by the time that it reaches
its peak you feel like your hand is being
burned away and you're in horrible agony and
she tells them don't pull your hand on the
box because if you do i'm going to poke you
with this needle and you're going to die and
an animal will you know chew its limb off
to get out of the trap or pull its hand out
of the box a human being can wait around and
try to kill its captor or it can defer um
it can defer you know it's it's it's actions
it can think about it right even when it's
being stressed because this is a horrible
thing to go through as a teenager too a young
guy and why does she do that to determine
whether he's really human the harkonnens clearly
are subhuman in their their beastial desires
and the question is well who else is genuinely
human what does it take to remain human when
you're in conflict you know because if you
want to have the human race survive it's the
humans you want to survive not just this dna
but actual human beings yeah i think there's
another dynamic we've just touched on a little
bit maybe a theme dynamic yeah goes back to
the super computer versus the super human
is that um the mahdi or paul and his development
is plagued by these dreams or visits and the
visions give of course get spiked up with
the spice eventually or maybe he's just coming
into his new role or whatever you can say
but i'm thinking that herbert was trying to
say that um the capacity to envision a future
or the future under different scenarios is
a very essential thing for the uh yeah the
life the wellness of where we're headed i
think that's yeah what i was trying to say
like when he says he has to go to take the
water of life because he didn't
so it's like that having you have to have
some sense of where we're going and um
we're going to go this way this is what's
going to happen yeah or whatever somebody
don't somehow stand out and take another somehow
or something that was yeah yeah you know you
see a few other characters in there like people
are planning stuff right like the harkonnens
have this plan right but there's other characters
like like the the kinds these imperial planetologists
who come up with this you know 500 year way
it's going to take all these things to make
arrakis fertile again a place where human
beings don't have to always be bringing the
waters of life yeah exactly
so that's an example too thinking differently
thinking about an alternative future and then
what would be required and that's distinctive
you're right that's distinctively human as
opposed to just thinking how do i screw my
enemies over you know i think i think there's
another thing which i'm like which will be
out and we're talking about artificial intelligence
yeah if if you look at what started but larry
and jihad oh yeah human beings thought they
could control architectural intelligence yeah
i left some of that then a jesuit thought
they could control the quizet hatarak yeah
the planetologists don't pay attention to
the real ecology and what causes the spice
yeah and they think they can control the ecology
and none of them can control any of it
there's a there's a human arrogance uh factor
in play i think yeah when we think we think
we can make better judgments that's one thing
that does come out um at a couple different
points like duke leto for example we'll talk
about and the mentats too we'll talk about
having to make decisions under situations
where we don't really know all the factors
that are going into it and we in philosophy
we call that somewhat pretentiously intellectual
humility you know like being or epistemological
humility sometimes we call that right most
people who talk about that don't strike me
as particularly humble
but it is it is an important thing you know
i'm not endorsing him for this but uh donald
rumsfeld i'm not i mean i'm not endorsing
all the rest of the stuff about realmsville
he said something actually really brilliant
that he got taken to task for years and years
and years ago and it was sort of a truism
he said you know there are no no's there are
known unknowns and then there are unknown
unknowns and he was talking about factors
in a complex situation and when i heard that
i was like that's really brilliant you know
forget how you feel about the guy for other
reasons that's actually a really brilliant
thing and figuring out how to tell the difference
between unknown unknowns where we got to be
really careful because we don't know what
the hell's going on and known unknowns where
we're like yeah i can go find out that information
you know i'll uh make this guy talk and now
it's no now it's a known known right figuring
that out the difference between those is what
kills people so much of the time yeah but
i think that phrase or concept was correlated
with another thing he said is we all get dealt
a hand and we play the hands of death okay
which is fatalism yeah innocence so then you
say well we got these unknown unknowns but
he's just playing the hand he's got delt inhale
so putting those two together maybe they shouldn't
have been or maybe they should be maybe that
wasn't his thinking another bromide though
i think trump stove is it
no i didn't mean that as a
yeah
there's some really interesting discussions
that i didn't have the time to like go back
and forth but there's a lot of discussions
about the nature of truth and put in characters
mouths i love some time to go back and actually
like you know this is a typical academic write
an article about theories of truth and how
they play out practically in in dune with
some of the characters one of the other uh
themes though we've gotta wrap up pretty soon
that i thought um and this ties in with this
this idea about knowledge that i thought had
some philosophical import is what's the nature
of the future um because paul is once the
spice opens up his consciousness he's able
to see all these futures right so you know
we think about we think about these things
in terms of images and that's the way it's
portrayed here in the book um we ought to
think about what is the future that paul is
knowing is it just sort of an imaginative
imagination is he seeing into timelines herbert
doesn't actually try to explain this he just
gives you some suggestive stuff um what is
annoying and then the other thing is does
knowing the future really help you does it
does it make you fatalistic right if you say
well now we know the future all right we're
screwed no you can't do anything different
or does it open up possibilities as soon as
human action gets involved the people who
are prescient like the guilt navigators for
example they reach a certain point then they're
like yeah don't know what happens after that
because somebody's going to do something what
they're going to do we don't know you know
and paul himself sees further than they do
but there's also places where he can't see
beyond because he knows that like he has to
make a decision and then you know the other
thing that comes up in this is knowing the
past some of the characters you know the reverend
mothers who use the water of life they're
able to access the memories of all these other
reverend mothers before them and sort of bring
them into their personality sometimes this
can be a bad thing like the unborn child and
jessica alia can be dominated by and she's
going to be dominated later in one of the
other books by one of the the the egos by
harconan actually by baron harkonnen but you
know paul can also do that too that's how
paul realizes that they are part of this bennett
jesuit breeding program and that the baron
harkonnen is actually his grandfather um that
jessica is actually his his daughter um so
you've got this looking to the future and
what is that what is the future about and
then you've got making sense of the past and
we look at the past as well that's done we
know all about it we've got our history books
but how much of the past do we really know
you know that's a good question how much of
the operative past do we really have a handle
on do we just are we only really seeing this
little slice here technology does some stuff
for us right we record things but there's
so much editing that goes in like we used
to do super eight movies and that was when
my dad had a super 8 and the things that he
thought were actually worth going around and
looking at all that's gone now you know some
people change them over to like digital files
but that's just such a tiny little slice of
the existence that it's supposed to be portraying
it gets taken like it's the whole of it you
know this person got photographed doing this
thing at this time so that's the way they
always are yeah and we know that's not the
case right it's what's deemed important at
that time by that person well they didn't
save your posterity and the state of the history
is written by the winners yeah yeah or whoever
happens to leave footage around them yeah
yeah you're right but we use that's right
we're recording it for and posterity and what
what significant piece of importance do you
want to remember from posterity and it's in
it's it's subjective they point out that everything
that's put in the time capsule is the least
informative really because you know they what
people think is going to be interesting and
as far as the future being able to affect
it i mean just as a quantum principle anytime
there's an act of observation it automatically
changes it so you know you can apply all these
different things to understand you know what
would be and you know the past is just a way
to learn how to behave into the future i mean
into the present so you know how to address
your future i mean that's you kind of pull
them all together you know like you take your
experiences from the past to my you know to
live your life now to make you so you can
be better in the future so you sort of miss
them all together yeah i think we're forgetting
i'm just making all that up right now no i
mean when it comes to like dealing with time
there is a there's certain you might call
them like a standard repertoire of positions
that that philosophers have discussed and
what you're talking about expresses one of
them because i think that we we don't have
like an unlimited number of options of how
we're going to look at time and so we naturally
fall into one or the other we're going to
say we take it for granted too that there
will be a video or a recording or something
like that a lot of the time you don't pay
the attention that we need to pay but i just
keep thinking about an assignment that i would
give writing students and i asked them to
find a photograph that they found to be particularly
striking and then write what happened before
or after and it was one of the things that
they struggled with the most because they
couldn't figure out the context and it was
really troubling because he wanted to be able
to craft either something super fantastical
or you know something that was just like completely
different from what they were saying in the
image because it felt too mundane and the
idea of just talking about what is was so
unappealing to them that more often than not
you know it could be a family photo and be
like and then a fight broke out there was
always some big drama you know it wasn't just
embellishments because because the ordinary
is just not yeah enough right yeah they used
to say about my mom she could every time she
told the story it was different than the last
time she told me maybe we just need to download
everybody's memories so then so they even
look at this file and we just compare them
against each other
two things one is as i've gotten older now
i've tried to go back and think about my family
yeah my parents never used a lot of never
took a lot of photographs and it was expensive
yeah i have virtually no pictures of the inside
of the house that i grew up in no yeah they
just yeah like what did the bathroom look
like what did the bedroom look like i had
an idea but the house burned down so it's
gone oh yeah can't go back and then the big
generalization is i found with a lot of people
in america most people don't care about history
they don't read it they don't study it they
don't think about it so so there is no past
well i don't
know
one of my uncles is particularly good that
way too you know he uh he's very funny you
know but you know you're never quite sure
what part of the story is invented and you
know yeah well uh that's probably a good place
to close because we're a little past times
thanks very much for a great conversation
and uh next time is roger zelazny the chronicles
of amber um july 15th 14th 14th i'll steal
me that's good because you know his main character
was in prison for a good portion